Ukraine is attempting to regroup
after Russia launched
its largest missile barrage
so far this year.
95 missiles
over the course of just the past day.
Ukraine's military says it was only able
to intercept about a third of them.
34 in Kiev.
Power and water have now been restored.
But, boy, it was a tough night.
Yeah, absolutely.
We are also watching
an event happening in Kiev right now.
It's a burial service
that's being held for a fallen
Ukrainian commander
who was killed in Baku.
CNN's Ivan Watson is there.
So, Ivan,
what more do we know about this commander
right.
Well,
this young man's name was Dmytro
Katsav Bylo.
He went by the codename Da Vinci.
And part of his funeral is taking place
here.
We've been watching
funeral and memorial events in Kiev
for hours now.
The church service was actually attended
by the Ukrainian
president, Volodymyr Zelensky,
and the top military command were in
Kiev's Maidan, that central square
where thousands gathered
to pay their respects
to this man
who was killed
this week
in the grinding battle of Mahmoud,
that small southeastern
Ukrainian city
where the Russian
and Ukrainian militaries
are pounding each other day
after day
for months now for control of that city.
Now, this man, Da Vinci, as he's
known last year, Zelensky,
the Ukrainian president,
gave him the honor,
calling him a hero of Ukraine.
And he is viewed by many of the people
who the thousands have gathered
as a national hero,
someone who participated
in the 2014 protests
the 2014 protests
against a pro-Russian president
in the Maidan Square
that ultimately resulted
in the overthrow of that president.
He fled to neighboring Russia.
So
da Vinci had been a young activist there
and then joined
a militia
that fought against
pro-Russian separatists
in the Donbass region
for years after that,
and then has been part of
the armed forces
fighting against the Russian invasion
over the course of the last year.
He is the youngest battalion
commander in the Ukrainian armed forces.
The crowds have been chanting things like
heroes never die.
And I think this underscores
the immense sacrifice
that Ukrainian military
commanders are paying in this battle.
This contest, this deadly contest
against the Russian military
in parliament.
Back to you.
Ivan Watson
live for us there this morning.
Ivan, appreciate it. Thank you.
Let's dove deeper in all of
this now with retired Brigadier
General Mark Kimmitt.
Good to have you on, sir.
Let's talk
first about this missile
barrage overnight.
One, it's the scope
hit across the nation.
Even killing people
all the way
in the western part of the country
seems to be a mix of a couple of things.
Hypersonic missiles,
difficult to impossible to shoot down
with Ukrainian air defenses,
but also these Iranian Shihad drones.
And it seems fired at the same time.
Is that by designed
to overwhelm Ukraine's air defenses?
Sure. Absolutely.
And it's their version of shock
and awe to
they're trying to make a huge effect
on the population and the infrastructure.
And are Ukrainian air defenses
even with the addition of more advanced
Western NATO's systems
still overwhelm there by these
these Russian missiles?
They are
I think until we see the patriot
get on to the ground
or they're going to
be on their back foot,
especially when you send
so many at once, it's
hard to target all of them,
hard to shoot them all down.
Another thing
this is CNN's reporting
is that
Russia is capturing
some Western made us supplied
in particular weapons
in the
in this fight
so far, including the javelin
anti-tank missile
and the Stinger shoulder
fired anti-aircraft missile,
sending them to Iran, in effect,
as a gift
for them to reverse engineer
potentially how significant is that?
Some gift?
Yeah, it's it's a boon to Iran.
Iran is providing drones to Russia
in return.
They're getting systems
so that they're reverse
engineering and propagating
throughout the region.
They've done this before.
Iran got a hold of the old TOW missile.
They got a hold of old drones as well.
So there's a Middle East regional impact
if you now see advanced weapons
being developed by Iran,
and if they show themselves,
for instance, with the tow
the ability to take one
figure it out and make their own.
Absolutely. That's alarming.
Okay.
Let's talk about the progress of war
then.
In the U.S.,
there's been a lot of talk
about a Russian spring offensive
really hasn't materialized.
U.S.
officials have been telling me
for some time
they just don't have the forces
and the manpower
to do anything definitive.
But we also know
Ukrainians want to carry out a counter
offensive in the opposite direction.
What is the actual state over here does?
Does either side have the potential
to make ground?
Well,
it really depends on what the Ukrainians
have been doing over the winter time.
Yes.
We've been focusing on it,
but hopefully
they've been resupplying,
rearming, retraining.
They really have almost an imperative
to have the spring offensive.
They've got to demonstrate
to the West
that they're making progress
that demonstrate to their own people
that they're making progress.
All the fighting,
all the attention around back
in these last several weeks.
Extremely deadly for both sides.
I mean, we're talking about
some days where thousands are killed
in a single.
24 hour period.
Has it been worth it for the Russians?
But also crucially for the Ukrainians
to fight so hard, so long
and to give up so much there?
I don't think so.
I mean, retrospectively,
this reminds me of World
War One, these great battles
where inches were gained
and thousands were lost.
Yeah.
This is
this is the area
we're talking about here.
So so what happens now
in the coming weeks?
You say
that Ukraine has to make
they have to make a push this way
just to not be on their back foot,
in effect.
Do they make progress
when they make that push?
Well, first of all,
I don't think
that's where they're going to do it.
If if I was advising them,
I would be looking at a different area.
There is a down here by Kherson
going all the way up to 30 on.
I think what they really want to try to
do is unhinge the Russian offensive.
Imagine if they were able
to get all the way to Bernie ask
they would
essentially put all of Crimea
at risk, particularly
if the Americans put an attack on us.
Right.
And then the Russians
are going to have to think
about this land bridge
that has been so important to them.
How will they react.
I mean that's
been one of the principal goals
of the whole Russian invasion is to join
Russian controlled areas here
with Crimea in the south.
Great point.
General Kimmitt,
always good to have your expertize.
Thank you.
President Lynskey has been clear
that this new tactic,
no matter what it is,
is still not going to make people
stand down.
I want you to take a
listen to what he said about it.
we have already
shown what Ukraine is capable of.
And no matter how treacherous
Russia's actions are,
Our state
and people will not be in chains.
Neither missiles
nor of Russia's
atrocities will help them.
Now, Russia's defense ministry
says this attack
is retaliation, retaliation
for an alleged cross-border attack
in Verdansk that took place
a few days ago.
Ukraine has denied involvement
in this attack.
But I think it shows
you it's
a reflection of the Kremlin's thinking
when retaliation looks like
attacking civilian areas.
And Sami, yesterday
when you joined
us, you mentioned how the ZAP region
to power
plant had been knocked off
the power grid for the sixth time.
I think in this conflict,
obviously raising a lot of alarm
among nuclear watchers.
What more do we know
about the safety of the plant
at the moment?
I think what really shook me is the quote
from the head
of the International Atomic
Energy Agency.
He said One day our luck will run out.
And that is the concern, right?
We're talking about a nuclear power plant
right on the front lines
that is Russian occupied,
but run by Ukrainian engineers
and Ukrainian staff
that has over and over again
been impacted by these massive missile
attacks, by these massive strikes
coming from Moscow
The IAEA is saying, look,
we have to do something about this.
This is dangerous.
This is something that is on the brink,
that is absolutely unacceptable.
And there's been several visits
of course,
by the nuclear watchdog,
but that has yet to
find a resolution to this.
So you're still looking
at Europe's largest nuclear power plant.
That's what
this Operation
Nuclear Power Plant
is caught in the crossfire
with no solution
as to how that plant can be stabilized
and people can be certain
that it doesn't become something worse
and something
running on emergency power, isn't it?
So it's not completely out.
Not completely out.
It goes into blackout mode.
So it's cut from the power grid.
But you're still talking
about a nuclear power plant. Right.
There are serious concerns
when you're talking about supplying power
to a nuclear power plant
and that supply not being stable
not being reliable.
Salma, thank you so much.